good morning John this week I flew in a
tiny plane to New York City where there
were many weird and fancy things here
are some of them white asparagus which
was fed to me at definitely the best
restaurant I have ever been to at least
the most expensive white asparagus is
just asparagus that has never seen light
and thus has a milder flavor and is not
at all green
this is went for two reasons one I feel
like I've robbed the asparagus of
reaching its full potential and two
because who figured that out my hotel
room had a mirror lens that I am rather
enjoyed there's a tip kids when your
umbrella breaks in New York City just
throw it on the ground this year and all
had ice in it why I don't know I don't
know pretty cool in the city of New York
to put this permanent installation in
tiffy OS clouds in Central Park I mean
that's just that's just real nice and
finally here are some tiny chairs that
cost much more than normal-sized chairs
see use Times Square and what's that oh
that's just an advertisement for the
movie they're making enema brothers book
the real reason why I was in New York
and yes it's great I wish I could have
seen more weird stuff but that's not why
I was there I was there to see the
premiere of The Fault in Our Stars the
first time I'd seen the movie and also
to walk down the red carpet which was
cool and lots of people took pictures of
me but maybe just cuz I asked them to
everybody take pictures I want a lots of
flashes yeah yeah say that because none
of them published any of the pictures
they took of me and my wife which is too
bad but good news my mom took a bunch
too also did you see how pretty my wife
is sweaty like there's nothing of sweat
rolling down my back right for my better
and then I watched a movie and I can't
show it to you cuz copyright
also that would be a really long YouTube
video and I'm having a hard time
figuring out what to say about it
because it was super surreal
so here's we're just gonna
intellectualize Piper intellectualize
cuz that's what I'm good at this is the
book that I finished while I was in New
York the shades of milk and honey is
like Jane Austen with magic in it one of
the big questions that book asks is are
beautiful things more or less beautiful
if you understand all of the hidden
systems that go into the creation of the
beautiful thing as I walked around New
York I kept seeing examples of hidden
systems on display like the escalator at
the Uniqlo had a window in the side so
you can see how the escalator worked on
the inside the Museum of Modern Art
Design Store which one can assume has
pretty good taste was just full of
examples of this stick for a long time
the trend has been to hide the
complexity to hide the systems in favor
of this illusion of effortless
perfection hide the technology inside of
the beautiful box rights aren't all
entertainment into a magic show
construct the celebrity as this perfect
embodiment of cool since we started here
on vlogbrothers we kind of been doing
the opposite that's the whole point this
is my real office I'm not wearing makeup
we make t-shirts with a local printer
here's how the process works John's book
is being turned into a movie here's some
videos of the cast and crew on set
here's how John feels about it and
here's how I feel about it right now how
I'm feeling is I'll be honest
overwhelmed I'm afraid that we're
missing opportunities I'm afraid that
every time I talk to the New York or The
Wall Street Journal that I'm just gonna
come up without the ability to say
things that make any sense and I'm
worried about all the external attention
but there is one thing that I'm not
worried about I'm not worried that
people won't like the movie or that the
movie is bad because it's not it's great
and people are gonna love it yeah I
cried I cried a bunch of times but not
because it's subtracted from me but
because it added to me it opened up the
mysteries of life and love and hurt for
examination and for understanding and I
think that that's something the world
needs more of John I'm proud of you
everybody go see the movie whenever it
comes out in your country on the day
that it comes out in your country on
I'll see you on Tuesday
an advertisement for the Buca di Beppo
in abracadabra whoo aha